ahs double feature has only two more
episodes until it's all over meaning
this is the second last preview
breakdown so hold your tears we're gonna
get through this and as always if you
haven't seen the preview before we begin
i'll leave a link to it in the
description below so this last episode
is called blue moon and the description
reads an unexpected visitor arrives at
the white house and reveals the details
of a very horrific plan this visitor is
likely cody fern's character we see
later on in the trailer the term blue
moon has come to mean several things
over time in a typical year we get 12
full moons but some years we get 13
which is referred to as a blue moon and
this happens about once every two and a
half years which is why a blue moon can
refer to a rare event and that old
saying once in a blue moon our first
shot is of marilyn monroe something has
alerted her to this open window and she
screams as a hand touches her shoulder
with previous footage we can determine
this is one of three things this alien
creature here which kinda has those same
long fingers as theta b it's a bunch of
secret agents or c this is on a film set
and it's a fake out president eisenhower
and vice president nixon are alerted by
earthquake-like rumbling and a bright
white light suggesting that this is that
unexpected visitor he tells everyone
there that what happened here today
never actually took place so this is
likely after his visit with cody fern
fast forward to these agents to what i'm
predicting is 1960s las vegas that's
because they're capturing calico and we
know from episode 8 that she has been in
captivity since the 60s she's also
wearing 60s type makeup and it's
interesting to note here that this part
is in color notice here the device used
to neutralize her is red instead of
green like what was used on kendall is
that because the tech has changed in
that time or is there something
different between kendall and calico we
then get this one or two frame shot of
someone laying on a table connected to
these wires just like kendall was but it
really doesn't look like calico to me i
have this not really great quality since
fx hasn't released their copy yet but to
me it kind of looks like it could be
cody fern or lily rabe's amelia earhart
now we see calico wake up in the same
facility as kendall and the others did
there are no other abductees here which
i find quite curious maybe she was one
of the first the president says what the
devil is going on here which is quite
funny since he'll be meeting cody fern
who played the devil in season 8's
apocalypse no word yet if there is an
actual connection between who he is
playing here and michael langdon it
looks like maybe has once again been
taken over by the aliens and here
eisenhower demands that she be let go we
get this brief shot kinda looks like it
could be an alien but to me it's a man
in a suit jacket now this is super cool
containers holding fetuses this may hint
at what happens to those babies once
they've grown to a certain size note
that they also have tails theta does her
best jedi impression looking as though
she's choking troy troy kept asking how
this baby will get out of him and this
leads me to believe it might come out of
his mouth here we get the backside of
cody fern's character tossing aside
white house security he can manipulate
stuff with his mind which is why i've
theorized in my episode 8 video that he
is the one behind taking control of mimi
and maria rumors have suggested that he
is playing valiant thor a representative
from an intergalactic high council which
some conspiracy theorists argue advised
top u.s officials what really interests
me here is this briefcase i'm super
stoked to find out what's inside but now
i want to turn it over to you what do
you think will happen next episode i
want to hear your thoughts and theories
in the comments below thanks for
watching everyone make sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much
you